let's start with possibly the greatest
match in Jiu Jitsu history your second
match against buchesha let's go through
the details let's go through the whole
thing so the walk leading up to it you
always do this walk it's an epic walk
you post that on Instagram henzo posted
on Instagram yeah this calm walk towards
the mat well let's go to that match in
particular what was going through your
mind you've been away from competition
facing probably one of the greatest and
at that time many people consider the
greatest Jiu Jitsu competitor of all
time in buchatcha uh here's the old man
the Old Timer getting back out there
what were you thinking yeah I think
that's the first time
since probably I got my black belt that
I was in the favor to walk into a fight
I have to say like a lot of people
thought consider him the favorite
I mean
understandable you know I was out of
competition for a while he was just
winning everything
so you know he's saying about the walk
like for me
you know the five stars way before the
referees say go you know it's uh is all
the focus and concentration
that I think is very important for me to
start before like you know I almost walk
blind to the Met many times I passed
like great friends and I couldn't see
anyone you know they're trying to talk
to you and I'm like I'm 100 focused on
my opponent already even thought that I
cannot even see him in front of me so I
think that's for me was always uh very
important to try to clear my mind out
from everything are you visualizing the
opponent I'm not just clearing not just
not at that time right is there what's
what's in your head is it like a calm
River with birds chirping
just blank Darkness yeah Darkness okay
and that's what we see in that calmness
it's just blankness how hard is it to
achieve that blankness it's difficult to
say because I think I don't remember
when I'll say probably as a black belt I
try to focus like that not to think
because
yeah it's probably something you learn
is the more you think the more nervous
you get and there's nothing that you're
gonna gain by thinking of the fight or
the possibilities what you know what you
can do what can go wrong what can go
right because it's unpredictable you
have absolutely no idea it's impossible
to predict the fight and you discover
that
if you just let those nervous feelings
go and empty your mind it actually is
pretty effective it is it makes you feel
better it's you know you you kind of
control your motion controlled
adrenaline on your body up to a level
so it absolutely helps you you know
focus in the fight I've learned that in
Jiu Jitsu and in general in life that
whenever something feels really shitty
you can just like take that thought and
not think about it yeah like I do that
like on long runs or like a fast run or
yeah in Jiu Jitsu especially not getting
older out of shape like that feeling of
exhaustion well you can always get to
the feeling of exhaustion you could just
not think about it yeah not think about
being exhausted yeah just and that's
somehow it relaxes you I think maybe in
the face of exhaustion all the fears
start to creep in maybe your muscles
tighten up I don't know this is for the
uh the amateur sexy person
but it's kind of funny how you can just
take that thought and let go of it so
you get as a black belt competitor you
get used to you get good at letting go
of any thoughts yeah for Innovation to
exhaustion is I mean that's not the good
example of it it's
you know there's a lot of times in the
fight you're getting tired and you're
getting pretty tired
so it's like the last scene you want to
think of it is how tight you are it
doesn't matter because it doesn't what
you're going to quit I mean it doesn't
matter yes how tall you are it's yeah
there's no value thinking about it
there's no value so you just have to go
through it so when you're like uh you
know many minutes into the match and
you're slowly moving as you sometimes do
tying your belt catching your breath
you're not thinking about anything
you're trying to let go of thinking I'm
trying to like to save
everything to the file like nothing goes
to waste it's you know every move
unnecessary it's it's just gonna make
you more tired or it's going to take
something out of you like you know I try
to calculate every single Move I Make
save as much energy as I can so I can
fully you know be focused 100 in the
fight with no way especially energy wise
and that's instinctual like uh
minimizing the amount of moves you're
not like
explicitly thinking should I do this or
not it's just just don't move unless
it's absolutely required yeah because
fight these you you cannot really
there's not really time to think much
you know it's like it's your instincts
are playing it's like it's
you know you already have your you know
your weapons let's say you know you did
the things that you do at is just you
wait for the perfect moment the beauty
of it is you know is there's the right
moment to everything if you feel one
second too late it doesn't work or you
get messy so it's you know you're trying
to catch that moment
that is you know and for that you have
to be fully focused in what you're doing
because one second you see you out it
won't work but you're you're not exactly
known as somebody that moves super
quickly so the so the moment
it's not about how quickly you move it's
about uh the right moment yeah yeah it's
not
like it's speed
it's not like you have to move the speed
of light it's it's the move itself at
that precise moment it doesn't have to
be super fast because your opponent's
not moving so perfect you know so this
is a combination of moving between you
and him I mean the same thing happens in
in Judo and the movement can be really
small yeah
Jude is a is a bit more explosiveness
you know she's the moves are slightly
faster so it did no it does require a
bit more explosiveness in Judo but even
just the right timing for an off balance
just a little tough yeah yeah it's not
that they're you know moving the speed
is not going to count that much yeah
it's the timing that you initiate that
move you see that with foot sweeps
there's nothing more beautiful than uh
like a Olympic level athletes going at
it in the Olympics and a person
and it's just and you see
one man's life flashed before his eyes
and realized like I'm supposed to be the
top three person in the world that I
just find they don't they have this look
on their face like I don't know what
just happened it's beautiful to see you
don't see that I guess you see that in
boxing knockouts and stuff like that you
don't know what the hell just happened
yeah is it that precise moment of
movement that you get caught like is is
that one Split Second
that's it do you get that in Jiu Jitsu
at all because Judo has
because of the explosiveness because of
the point scoring system that
incentivizes these giant throws
um has these moments where everything
just turns on a single moment do you
have that in Jiu-Jitsu not really
because Dennis points is you get like
you know two points so he's
because I think regarding the submission
is not just one precise movement that
changed everything I think Judo is the
takedown that counts as a submission
like keep on fight over Jujitsu don't
have that
so you will you will score points but I
think in terms of submission you need to
get to uh in a dominant position first
and then the submission will come slower
it's a process yeah